hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
how the heck are you fortnight season X
has become a crazy meme world in week 7
if you are new around these parts every
week we meet up and go through all the
changes in the world some are huge
hulking and obvious but sometimes there
are small updates to keep us on our toes
using this information we attempt to
build a story theory and by the way this
week's one is a really good one if you
have the battle pass I think you'll like
it so relax for 10 minutes use code atom
arrow in the font night shop for a shout
out and let's go through every change in
fortnight season x week 7 this week the
visitor has been placing down not one
but two rift beacons in the wilderness
the first at the frozen town below polar
peak and the other is over at Paradise
Palms the problem is though the nexus
point is now struggling with this extra
workload and disaster looks imminent I
don't think it can take another beacon
to be honest but before we discuss that
let's jump into these new areas crazy
mother
Griese grove is back baby another one of
everyone's favorite drop locations we
all think back to fondly but do you
notice the difference is greasy has
changed the basketball court for one is
in a completely different position and
so are many of the houses suggesting
once again that this location is not
from our history it's from another
fortnight dimension and to compound that
more the original der burger which went
out of business here is no more where
ever this island came from tack holes
were all the rage could they see the
return of the food fight which ripped us
all apart which side would you choose by
the way oh and one of the strangest
things I've ever seen in fortnight's
happens in this new greasy Grove tack
holes fall from the sky and healers as
we dance you can't write this it's
ridiculous but perfectly ridiculous so
that means that we have to say goodbye
to frozen greasy and that lovely ice
cube building did you ever go inside the
one with the frozen fish and the
unreachable chest thanks for the
memories but now it's time to make new
ones and by the way the fish is now on
the wall dance here for a guaranteed win
it's true it's damn true check the
comments if you don't believe me so over
to the other rift zone moisty Palms
which sounds awful kind of wrong to me
in this area we can hide as a prop so so
strange isn't it this means that we will
see YouTube completely filled with mean
videos as your favorite youtubers all
hide as toilets hilarity ensues it will
also though makers unbelievably nervous
when passing through this area as any
second a toilet could shoot you
nightmare fuel also you've got to emote
when you're in this form it's absolutely
stupid fun ever seen a cactus playing a
guitar whilst flying on a drone no you
have you're welcome parts of moisty
might have returned too so have fun
running around as a burn in fact have
you ever seen a fern weight-lifting you
have now sorry I'll stop but here's the
best part which I'm most excited about
the prison has returned a legit landed
here every time in season two what about
you it's still part of moisty powers
though so don't ever trust a bottle
flipping toy
another part of this area of the map is
further north the gas station returns
from the first moisty Meyer update back
in season 3
damn anyway let's move away from mean
culture and to other map updates you
should be aware of some are tiny for
example do you ever jump off the meteor
and attempt to land on the factories but
made it well this week it's possible
meaning the meteor is moving
unbelievably slowly closer to dusty
Depot and whilst we're here on the
meteor have you noticed that the
electricity bolts and throbbings are
becoming more often and a little more
intense whatever magic is holding this
ball of metal in the sky is beginning to
wear off this big boot I'm calling Betty
is inevitably going to hit dusty so the
visitor needs to get a move on over
there if it doesn't want to get blown up
by Betty so let's move to dusty have you
seen it this week the visitor is how to
work but this week is completely
different
check out this erection I think he's
trying to steal hot watches limelight
what could it be far though the
extruding part is a metal frame used to
stabilize something and judging by the
lowered floor inside whatever it is can
fly using thrusters so we can take this
two different ways either he's making a
hybrid mech from all the brute pass he's
been scanning for the last fortnight hey
I used fortnight in a fortnight video oh
yeah me are alternately which we all
expect he's once again building the
rocket from back in season four in one
of our theories we talked about the
original rocket being lost in time and
the visitor needs to make a brand
spanking new one to escape the island
before the meteor hits at all in fact
this ties into today's story theory can
we just take a moment to celebrate the
way dusty has evolved from a storage
shell to a makeshift base to a living
home to a complex tech room to a beacon
workshop and now a potential rocket
launch pad epic games you get a lot of
stick for what you do but this part of
what you do is phenomenal keep it up
so the other thing which will impact the
story is the nexus point at live Lake
that of off power each week the visitor
has harnessed more of that power causing
the optic further and now the energy
field emitted from the AAB looks like
it's going to explode sooner or later or
maybe the power will run out what do you
think will happen here I'd love to know
because I want to include it in next
week's story so let me know your
thoughts oh hang on
where are my manners let's get the most
important thing covered she's still here
I was so certain that Kevin's island was
going to crush it into oblivion but look
it's still here cue the heavenly music
this week our Hut has got what a veneer
coating it looks like birch I think so
technically our Hut is the son of a
birch that sounds like a really good
t-shirt design I'm so proud so I still
believe that Kevin will come back and
destroy the huts so we decided to
celebrate Hut watch with a bottle flip
competition thanks to those who took
part you guys you've got skills we've
seen Hut watch structures built we've
seen triple flips in Mason's video he
destroys Kevin with a bottle flip linked
below if you want to see some of those
videos but the winner is DJ datas who
used launch pads to land on the hood and
land a bottle flip the first time I've
commented on your video check it for how
to claim your prize let's move on to the
tiny stupid updates which make no sense
have you noticed the TV house at spawn
island is losing its TV slowly
well now pandora has it gone we can see
where they're going get your butt over
to West world's and look at the
evolution of the TV house Wow
it's a masterpiece and pro tip another
guaranteed way to win a match is to sit
on the chair here you think I'm lying
don't you check the comments I know
that's any update makes the Statue base
at Haunted Hills completely unbreakable
I know this is probably nothing but the
last time I didn't point something out
like this the statue became a freaking
sword in the live event
damn that was a good live event okay so
I think that's all the map updates if
you spot something I haven't please give
me a message and I'll make sure it's
included next week much appreciated
thank you now it's time for our story
theory so grab the popcorn
okay this week's theory is based around
a new world and it's also based around
the battle pass and why we are getting
characters that we already have but
that's slightly different of course
anyway it's all about combining
alternative dimensions if you're ready
let's do this we all know by now the
story of the original visitor arriving
inside a meteor before breaking free
searching the island for ways to escape
and finally using a hidden rocket to
leave our island but something happened
that night which we are only just
beginning to understand the multiverse
the visitor has become a Time Lord
during his travels he's fought nights
answer to doctor who cross with
something from back to the future now so
many seasons later the visitor has
perfected intergalactic time travel and
turned back the clock and returns to the
island both in the past and the present
how is that possible he is where things
are becoming slightly clearer the
visitor creates the rift beacons all
around the island which used the power
of the nexus point over at loot lake but
this power supply won't last many more
uses it is breaking in front of our eyes
the visitor programs those rift beacons
to pull locations from the same
fortnight island but from hundreds of
different dimensions all with slightly
different timelines in one dimension
Pandora is created due to a lack of
policing resulting in bandits taking
over in another dimension the husks have
infected the entire island and some
islands remained in the past refusing to
evolve but why is the visitor doing this
the clues are right in front of our eyes
in the battle pass all unlockable skins
are already part of our universe the
visitor is finding alternative
dimensions to bring together key carrier
needed to save our world or begin a new
world once the Nexus explodes time
travel will be stopped and the island
will be left in pieces knowing this the
visitor brings together seven characters
from seven different dimensions but
here's something he didn't expect each
of those characters found themselves the
versions we know from our world
human nature brings people together
finally the visitor recruits each pair
for the new world arriving in three
weeks the voyages are the first to be
recruited due to their knowledge of
space travel next the first person to
ever be brought through a rift is
recruited drift and his partner
catalysts to be prepared for war in this
new world the black knight and Ultima
Knight join forces to be the colony's
protectors due to their tactical skills
the rust labs found each other at junk
Junction their desire to scavenge
salvaged and collect will be vital
skills going forward the new world also
needs creativity music and dance with DJ
yonder finding his alter ego in yonder
yard and technique finding her
doppelganger over at the old retail rope
finally Sparkle specialist is chosen to
lead the group due to her compassion and
once she's matched with her twin the
team is assembled the Nexus has weeks or
maybe days until Cataclysm it has
reached its breaking point our our
heroes ready for a new world created
from multiple dimensions the live event
is imminent at the end of the island
draws close the visitors plan is in full
motion
[Music]
so what do you think that that one
the reason time travel and
interdimensional travel is so important
is because we are merging together
multiple worlds but let's be honest we
still don't know the direction of the
story so this is just another theory
we've had six attempts at this now and
they've all been completely different so
we'll try something different next week
to give me a shout if you have anything
to add to the stories I am always
reading theories I love them oh and I
quit thank you to those in my discard
for helping me with this theory I could
not have done this without you I'll make
sure the discard link is in the
description if you want to get involved
in these kind of things so there we have
it seven weeks deep into season X it's
been a troublesome season I'm sure you'd
agree but the story is just hotting up
like usual here's the legends roll call
for those people who use code a tomorrow
in the fort night shop and DM me on
twitter with a vid of them buying
something new in the shop hopefully all
you legends can find your names here
okay let's call this a day please book
me in next week and we'll do all this
all over again I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade oh and if you've got this fire
in the video please write sausage dog
I'll try and find you and give you some
live thanks for your time see you soon
[Music]